you know one of the fun parts of the
documentary on the last dance the Jordan
documentary with the Bulls is you're
seeing footage and you're seeing a lot
of these people that I saw pretty much
every summer
in May and June where you'd see them
when I'd be out there with the Sports
Center and you'd see the Chicago Bulls
playing against whoever Seattle or if it
was Utah or Portland or the Lakers
whoever it would be and one of those
people I always enjoyed running into
because he always had something smart to
say something smart that he was writing
about with Sam Smith he wrote the book
the Jordan rules he also co-authored
Derrick Rose's autobiography I'll show
you Bulls dot-com writer long time Bulls
NBA writer Sam it's great to see ya
thanks for joining us how have you been
I've been great Dan good to see again I
see you're not yes I finally left I'm
glad you stayed following my career Sam
that's why you're a great reporter when
you were tell people what the Jordan
rules was about you know it's sort of
double untimed in a sense and that was
not covered in the documentary not that
it should be either I'm sort of a you
know a play off the Pistons defense
which was essentially a trapping defense
when they finally realized you know we
can't play this guy we've got great
defenders Joe Dumars Dennis Rodman and
he's beating us all by himself so we're
gonna double-team and triple-team him
and just guide him to places on the
floor for Jordan rules and well the
Bulls Jordan rules and sometimes was and
Phil Jackson used to say a lot you know
the pretty girl gets kissed you around
Phil a lot said you know the Bulls had
an internal rule it was sort of a joking
thing internal rule that you know if you
were sick you had to come in and see the
trainer get treated get medicine go home
and when Jordan got sick the trainer
went to his room so they were different
Jordan the rules but the book
essentially was just supposed to be
you're really innocent and simple diary
of a season back then if you remember
you know Bird and Magic were the NBA
Isaiah you know was about sharing it was
about making players better
it wasn't about scoring and the notion
was well no Michael you can't win with
Michael people wrote that all the time
said you know he's great he's a star
he's the MVP we love watching him but
you're not gonna have a winning team
that way because he scores too much he
doesn't involve his teammates so the
Bulls are trying to get through the
Pistons and I've been traveling with the
team several years and thought oh you
know I had had my dream job working for
a newspaper all really everyone it was
great fun and I see these guys have
written books and read books and now
that I'm starting to meet him and they
go well they're not so smart maybe I can
do that too so David Halpern stands
breaks in the game around the place
Blazers in the late 70s was always like
really my favorite basketball book
because it was a story you know beyond
the game about the people and the
elements of being a team together of the
season so I said well maybe I'll do
something like that in my spare time and
you know what's more important in life
is for the most part is well he'll think
these days of course but being in the
right place at the right time and I
happened to be you know picked the
season 1991 and instead of Jordan
breaking his foot in game 3 like you did
at 86 85 86 the Bulls end up upsetting
Portland doesn't get there they were
favored then they beat magic in the
finals and now I've got a diary of
Michael Jordan and the Bulls winning a
title which happens to come out right
about the time Jordan skips the trip to
the White House to go on a gambling
weekend with slim bull or in a bunch of
this unbeknownst to him you know
convicted convicted drug dealers and
things so everything sort of blows up at
once this story gambling all this sort
of stuff and I'm and I'm going you know
I was just said hey I would just wanted
to peel back the curtain a little bit to
show you what a season's like did Jordan
know you were writing that book oh yeah
they all know guy had I had told guys to
season and when I'm proud about the book
I mean of course it's taken 30 years and
now I've got validation cuz Michael's
sort of cop to it now and said yeah that
could be a jerk sometimes
you know cuz back then
as well little Michael is the perfect
you know marketing figure and he's up in
the tree house to deliver the kids coke
and coca-cola and his with the shoes and
the kids are dancing and singing be like
Mike and well how could he be like this
you know how could he say you know
Horace Grant you can't eat today on the
plane going home because you played
badly or you know Bill Cartwright don't
throw him the ball because see he's got
15 fingers he won't catch it throw it to
him you throw it to him I'm not throwing
it to you Michael wouldn't do those
things and so now Michael you know that
is to meet have been the great thing
about the auto you about the documentary
seeing him the way we saw him in the
eighties you know open and funny and
challenging and and and these interviews
had just been the best part of it to me
and then he changed Sam it was really in
the early night honestly the the
confluence of events you know the
celebrity the success and now the
controversies again obviously the book
to some extent and I said I've I haven't
traveled them with the team several
years and told all the players and him
to before we had a good relationship I
played golf with him and been around him
a lot and said yeah I'm gonna write a
book about the behind the scenes with
the team but nobody's gonna lose their
job and nobody's gonna be embarrassed
with their family it's just gonna be
what it's like and that's what I felt
there was then with with that then the
gambling thing comes up you know he had
skipped the trip to the White House to
do this imagine what that would be like
today you know and then you know in New
York during the playoffs he's not going
to Atlantic City he goes to Atlantic
City and the New York papers make a big
fuss about it which was really a stupid
story but nevertheless he's starting to
feel all these years and I've sat and
talked with you guys and being
accommodating and he really was the best
guy in the league to deal with for it
star maybe magic there's only one even
close as far as accommodating and
friendly and open and
manoa Sencha Lee from that point on he
began to become reclusive to the point I
mean when he once he retired he'd become
this complete recluse which so I've
really been surprised he did the
documentary but again he's so far out
ahead of all
of us you know that this thing just
becomes this this icon it's amazing what
the documentaries because I think it's
strategic I thought of his brilliant
marketing Sam on a couple of fronts he's
introducing himself to a new generation
reintroducing himself to our generation
but he's also sending a message to
LeBron James and any of his fans that
hey you think LeBron is getting up there
near me the fact that he agreed to do
this documentary on the day LeBron won
the title with Cleveland Sam that's not
a coincidence this is a it's a 10 10
hour reminder of just how great Michael
Jordan is yeah I'd like to say that not
the case but but actually think how was
your relationship with Jordan oh he
doesn't really have relationships with
media people for the most part because
you know he doesn't have to he owns a
team he's a billionaire and he just
built his own golf course but once he
came back in 95 and and you know you see
now with the interviews I'm Michael
Jordan you know buddy I'm sort of litmus
snowstorm to him all of us are you know
so I've run into a few times in
Charlotte with the Bulls and I still
travel occasionally with the Bulls are
right on that team website now and he
was great one time like a couple of
years ago storming in Charlotte and he
said hey I just got back you know just
came up from Jupiter and the changing
diapers today that's what at whatever
maybe he was maybe he wasn't but it
sounded like a good story so he's you
know he's been good he come he come
around but he interesting thing is he
never comes to Chicago ever even even at
the all-star game this year
he never even came out and made an
appearance so it was remarkable but
maybe now with and the other thing when
you said with the timing with the LeBron
and everything he's actually a figure
for this era more than any because you
know this is not an era of death you
know this is an era of you know like
success highlights you know and many
have announced that and he sort of fits
perfectly into this because he's you
know he's he's well-spoken good-looking
you know and and
comes up with hotcakes all the time he's
like he's like involved perfectly into
this era what did the documentary not
capture if you're gonna have one one
item yeah it's you know to me it's sort
of like based on a true story you know
like you see a lot of these I think I
think everything they're talking about
basically happened but elements of it
yeah yeah you know get forgotten about
you know like like when he provoked the
Pistons into that walkout he really did
they were up three out of Bulls and he
went to practice the day before I
remember sitting there and he just
eviscerates this 2-time champion
three-time Finals team as unworthy
shouldn't be a champion the NBA should
take away their trophies and that's
really what motivated and to do this it
wasn't this walkout that you know this
revisionist history two Pistons came up
with later and you know you know I've
also loved the you know the Seinfeld
Festivus thing where he's airing of all
his grudges still 30 years later you
know Krauss and I say everybody you know
making fun of Gary Payton how dare
anyone challenge me it's been amazing
stuff it's been it's been just great
stuff to watch yeah and it's it's you're
right it is based off a true story
because Michaels team is helping produce
this and Michael gets the last word with
everything you know so it's I look I
enjoy it because it's a chance to let
people in you know the window into our
world back then Sam when it was pretty
crazy following the Bulls you did it
every day I was there for the finals and
I as I told people back then and remind
them now Michael every NBA Finals that I
was there for ESPN he would tell the PR
guy Tim Mowlem and he would say Tim
would come in and say Mike's not going
to do after every win he'll do it after
every championship you know once we win
the championship he'll come in and he's
gonna do the interview with you on
SportsCenter I I mean that was magical I
I was so lucky that I was there to help
document that and you know
I forever indebted to ESPN allowing me
to have that moment to capture that with
Michael Jordan whether I have a
relationship or you know he likes me or
didn't want me in the documentary I
couldn't care less I was there to see
that upfront personal and yeah that was
magical it really was it was a magical
magical time yeah you know going through
history you know and it's your
day-to-day life you don't sort of
realize it you know I wasn't at the
Gettysburg Address okay not sure after
that but I'm sure those people you know
in Gettysburg listening to Lincoln going
well you know they're not thinking 200
years from now people are going to be
talking about this and asking me where I
was but you know and that's what it was
we're running into the airport we're
trying to catch a next plane get to the
nega you know but also reminds me you
mentioned Tim Hallam with that it
reminds me of what it was like with
Michael because even before the just
before the championships we'd be
traveling and everybody wanted to see
him and you see a lot of these you know
after the game celebrities and Jerry
Seinfeld around and whoever and so we
were in Washington one time and somebody
came in and said Tim about this Queen
from some European country or something
wanted to see Michael and Mike they came
in and Michael said he was busy being
taped or whatever in Tim's today there's
a queen in every city we do you realize
this Sam I don't know if anybody ever
did a story on this and maybe you could
tell me if it's true or not
every time I interviewed Jordan after he
won a title every single time he had his
shoes off and Tim Hallam had him with
him and I remember Tim saying that
Michael always promised me his shoes and
I I'm gonna guess Tim has six pairs of
Michael Jordan shoes from when he won
those six titles did you ever hear this
now actually Michael used to give away
the shoes all the time you know he wore
a different pair of sneakers at every
game he played his entire career but
this is the NBA Finals Clinton I mean I
know that if Tim's got those I'm gonna
check that out but I'm surprised he's
still working if he's got those yeah
Tim's got a new house I think
he paid for it in shoes there but yet
Mike would come in shirttail out
drenching champagne Cuban cigar and Tim
Hollen would be behind him with his shoe
he would one time he said Mike take off
your shoes and he Mike took off his
shoes before he did the interview with
us and gave him to Tim and I think that
was what Tim that's all he ever asked
from Michael was can I have your shoes
after we win the championships and
that's a big it's actually a big ask oh
my gosh yeah I don't like a Michael
Jordan's sign shoes game-worn
championship shoes yeah yeah that's yeah
I got it goes tim is still working for
the Bulls in the same job and he dresses
very modest it's a smart movie doesn't
want to let anybody read between the
lines there it's great to talk to you
Sam and I meant when I said I enjoyed
all of those years being able to be out
there in Chicago the wonderful members
of the media for the most part and just
you're right and you know I look back
and I I'm reminded that we got to
Chronicle history and we got to be
around you know somebody that will never
be around again in our lifetime yeah it
was great fun it's good to see you again
and hopefully if there's another great
documentary I'll get on your show thank
you Sam that's a Sam Smith the author
the Jordan rules also he wrote the
Derrick Rose way co-wrote that Derrick
Rose all show you that's available on
triumph books calm Amazon Barnes and
Noble and through your local independent
bookstore